[Music]
on this monday night afghanistan marks a
dark anniversary
one year of the taliban's rule
one family's bittersweet journey to
canada and the push for ottawa to pick
up the pace helping refugees
on high alert we could be in for a
really chaotic and dangerous time the
rising threats against the fbi preparing
for battle
the recruits getting ready to take on
russian forces and quest for a cure all
we're trying to do is give them just a
better life one family's multi-million
dollar fundraiser for their son and
others with a very rare disease
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser good
evening thank you for joining us
one year ago today was a dark day for
the people of afghanistan the taliban
entered kabul capturing afghanistan's
capital and wiping out two decades of
significant gains in democracy human
rights and education
in the past 12 months the economy has
collapsed hunger is rampant and under
the cover of borquez women's freedom has
vanished
today in kabul taliban fighters
celebrated chanting victory slogans
outside the now closed u.s embassy
they have declared august 15th a
national holiday
but there are still brave scenes of
resistance over the weekend dozens of
afghan women took to kabul streets
demanding the right to work study and
participate in society
taliban fires quickly broke up the
protest by firing their guns into the
air putting an end to the first women's
protest in months
after a year of governing the taliban
has yet to be recognized by a single
country in the world western governments
have been scrambling to evacuate their
own citizens and help those who help
them
canada has fallen far short of its plan
to resettle 40 thousand afghans
thousands are still trapped in
afghanistan and those who have arrived
are still haunted by their difficult and
painful journey jeff semple has our top
story tonight
the ahmadi family's arrival to canada is
bittersweet the father bashir used to
work for the canadian forces in
afghanistan
when the taliban retook control of the
country one year ago he and his family
went into hiding they spent months
trying to escape
they finally made it here to edmonton
last spring
but without one of their children
i'm happy that my family is here bashir
says but i also feel anxious i feel
crazy because i lost my daughter last
december beshear's family had received
approval to go to canada as refugees but
with no rescue flights they first needed
passports to get themselves to pakistan
one night while waiting for their
applications to be approved
the family drove through a taliban
checkpoint in kandahar and the guards
started firing at their vehicle
beshear's ten-year-old daughter nacifa
was shot in the head
my old family was there and they were
shocked
the cifa's uncle was driving behind them
in a second car he says the vehicle was
so riddled with bullets a fire broke out
the taliban guards refused to help him
pull his family members from the burning
wreckage i shouted at them
what are you waiting for
they were just glancing on them but they
didn't help me
their aunt seated next to nasifa also
died two other family members were
injured
bashir says he'd previously received a
warning letter from the taliban accusing
him of being a western spy he believes
his family was targeted because he'd
worked for the canadians
when we first spoke to bashir and broke
the news of nasifa's death last year it
sparked a national outcry and a pledge
from the immigration minister to do more
to help
but one year since ottawa promised to
bring forty thousand afghan refugees to
canada around seventeen thousand or
fewer than half have arrived a
significantly slower pace than refugees
arriving from syria in 2015 or ukraine
today
this particular refugee resettlement
initiative is easily the most
challenging that we could imagine in
canada the immigration minister blames
the taliban for the delays getting
refugees out of the country but nasefa's
family is calling on ottawa to move
faster some of their family and friends
are still waiting for their applications
to be processed yeah i request the
government of canada
as soon as possible
because and as we enter our life for the
government of canada
they should also equal evo acquaintance
and
our family too
since arriving in canada four months ago
bashir's wife gave birth to a son they
called him muhammad siraj which means
light
a symbol of hope for the future and the
darkness they left behind
jeff semple global news
as you heard in jeff's story while the
canadian government blames the taliban
for delays in getting refugees to safety
opposition leaders blame the liberals
for not doing enough global news circled
back with the minister in charge for
more details on canada's response as
thousands of accounts wait in dangerous
limbo tom vernon reports
it is the story of thousands of afghan
citizens women and men who stepped up to
help canadian forces during a time of
war i have the honor and privilege to
serve for the canadian army this man who
needs to keep his identity secret served
as an interpreter for the canadian army
even earning a commendation and
promotion
one year ago his life changed
dramatically kabul fell to the taliban
canada quickly evacuated its embassy
staff leaving behind those who supported
our efforts with promises of bringing
them to canada soon
for this veteran who has since fled to
pakistan that promise is still
unfulfilled after sending numerous
emails
up to now i have only received an
automated reply instead of expeditious
processing the application process is
opaque
confusing and marred in bureaucratic red
tape ndp mp jenny kwon says canada's
evacuation response has been
unacceptable and is demanding the
government expand the program reduce
documentation requirements and allow
refugees to complete their paperwork
after they've landed safely in canada
they are real people
all within an enduring relationship with
canada
and feel abandoned by the canadian
government the conservatives agree
calling the liberal response shameful
the liberal government was saying that
we'll do everything we can to get them
out but their actions are speaking
louder than that i'm the kind of person
who will always want to do more to go
faster the minister in charge says he's
always willing to listen to ways to
improve the program but he says the
biggest obstacle isn't the paperwork but
safe passage out of afghanistan in the
past 12 months to have resettled 17
hundred afghan refugees in canada uh by
global standards uh it's it's uh amongst
the the most anyone could hope to this
interpreter still waits fearing for his
life and the lives of his family he was
forced to leave behind this is the
matter of life and it i need an
immediate intervention to work with me
and my family and give me a chance to
live and serve in canada with dignity
and pride tom vernon global news
edmonton
it has been one week since a search
warrant was executed at donald trump's
florida home and the rhetoric from
supporters of former president trump
keeps ramping up while republicans have
long described themselves as the party
of law and order many trump supporters
including those in congress are now
taking aim at the country's top law
enforcement agency the fbi has reported
an increase in threats and even calls
for an armed rebellion and civil war
jackson proskow reports
security is visibly tighter at fbi
offices after a weekend intelligence
bulletin warned of an increase in
threats to federal law enforcement
officers and even their families
including threats of a dirty bomb
outside fbi headquarters and general
calls for civil war and armed rebellion
as soon as the news broke
about the fbi search of mar-a-lago
there was a tidal wave
of
anger and animus
that came from radical supporters of
president trump donald trump's
possession of top secret documents has
led the justice department to probe
possible violations of the espionage act
and obstruction of justice
on monday trump claimed the fbi even
took his passports in the search
all the while the former president and
his allies have kept up their verbal
attacks on the fbi some naming agents
and even the judge who authorized the
search warrant the fbi has been acting
like a bunch of thugs i don't know if
they're director they're just doing it
on their own who is to say
in this kind of case that some of the
documents supposedly seized were not
planted there to begin with
over the weekend trump supporters
rallied outside local fbi offices the
fbi has been specifically targeting
conservatives in this country
last week's attack on an fbi office in
cincinnati was carried out by a trump
supporter armed with a nail gun and an
ar-15 style rifle he posted extensively
on trump's truth social site if a small
swath of republicans take it seriously
and follow through
turning their violent threats into
violent action
you know we could be in for for a really
chaotic and
dangerous time trump told fox news he's
willing to help bring down the
temperature because of what he called
tremendous anger in the country yet
there's little sign of what steps he
might take to make that happen at a time
when multiple investigations could
deliver serious consequences what makes
the current threat so difficult to
confront is that they're not
concentrated around a single date or
event like we saw with january 6 but
each day closer to november's midterms
and each new revelation in the trump
investigations seems to heighten the
risks
farah
jackson prosco in washington thank you
jackson and rudy giuliani donald trump's
former personal attorney has now been
told he is the target of a criminal
investigation into his efforts to
overturn the 2020 election prosecutors
in georgia say the former new york mayor
has become a focus of their election
interference investigation giuliani is
scheduled to testify before a special
grand jury in atlanta later this week
following the election giuliani
repeatedly claimed electronic voting
systems in the state were misused to
alter ballots and more than 60 000
ineligible votes were cast those claims
were debunked by multiple investigations
the uk has taken a major step in
fighting covid19 it is now the first
country to approve a vaccine designed to
target both the original virus and the
more transmissible omicron variant the
country's medicine regulator approved
moderna's new bivalent vaccine for
booster shots citing clinical trial data
showing a strong immune response against
both virus variants the agency also says
it is still providing good protection
against omicron's ba4 and ba5
sub-variants there are no details yet on
when those doses will be publicly
available
a major change in canadian media ctv is
parting ways with lead national anchor
and senior editor lisa laflem
while it is crushing to be leaving ctv
national news in a manner that is not my
choice
please know reporting to you has truly
been the greatest honor of my life
leflamb broke the news herself on social
media saying she was blindsided shocked
and saddened by the move in a statement
ctv calls it a business decision made
due to changing viewer habits la flem
was appointed ctv's national anchor in
2010 after decades of reporting from all
over the globe ctv is named omar
sachidina as la flam's replacement
it's a critical education on combat
coming up the ukrainian civilians
learning to become soldiers
an angered china staged fresh new
military drills near taiwan today this
in response to another sudden visit from
u.s lawmakers to the island beijing
claims as its own
chinese forces carried out more air and
sea combat exercises in the region with
their defense ministry adding in a
statement they will crush any form of
taiwan independence separatism or
foreign interference this comes just
days after china concluded aggressive
drills over u.s house speaker nancy
pelosi's earlier high profile visit
meanwhile this latest congressional
delegation met with taiwan's president
and senior officials to discuss security
obligations and trade issues before
leaving the country earlier today
the ukrainian military is battling hard
but the grinding war is taking a toll on
its forces and now canadian troops have
arrived in the uk to help train
thousands of volunteers to fight russia
up to 225 canadians will soon form part
of an international group giving basic
military training to ukrainians with
little or no military experience our
redmond shannon got to see some of that
training up close at a military base in
england
recreating the fog of war or at least
attempting to
these are everyday civilian ukrainians
who have volunteered to fight against
russia's occupation of their country
spending the next few weeks at this
military base in england to learn the
basics of how to become soldiers
i want my children grandchildren
will live in
free independent
and flourishing country
this recruit who goes by the nickname
zakar says his motivations are deeply
personal as well as patriotic
emily
my friend was killed in odessa
that's why it's also my aim
to revenge for him
because
we know that a lot of
common unguilty people are dying under
the bombardment the aim at least
initially is to give 10 000 ukrainians
basic military training over the coming
months i mean it's been humbling
absolutely
they are really motivated all of them
i've not seen one yet who's put his hand
up and went no i don't want to do this
the their will to win is fantastic
within weeks canadian forces will join
the british as trainers here part of an
international alliance of this uk-led
training programme up to 225 soldiers
from canada for a four-month commitment
most from the third battalion of
princess patricia's canadian light
infantry in edmonton some are already
here and getting ready to start it's a
pretty profound thing when you think
about it
so what it means for us is it's really
important to deliver hard realistic
training for the short time we have them
and
and i guess prepare them for what lies
ahead this will be a resumption of
canada's operation unifier training
mission but now with much higher stakes
it was paused when russia invaded
ukraine in february over the previous
seven years canadian forces had
instructed 33 000 ukrainian soldiers and
security personnel canadian special
forces are also on the ground in ukraine
conducting training exercises there too
redmond shannon global news in the
southeast of england
one month after russia announced it
would be pulling its support of the
international space station a model of
the country's planned replacement has
been unveiled
russia says it will quit the iss at the
end of 2024 in favor of its own orbital
station russian state media says the
first component for the new station
could be launched as early as 2025 and
completed by 2035.
more raging wildfires in europe ahead
the inferno in spain forcing hundreds to
flee
more than 1200 families have been forced
from their homes due to a trio of fierce
and fast-moving wildfires in spain
gusty winds and difficult terrain is
making for challenging firefighting
conditions forcing crews to rely on
planes and helicopters to attack the
flames drought and long stretches of
extreme temperatures have made 2022 the
worst fire year of the century with
spain recording 43 major fires so far
four times the number last year kenya's
deputy president william rudow has won
the country's fiercely contested
presidential election
these are the chaotic scenes inside the
maine tallying center as the result was
announced rudol narrowly beat his main
opponent veteran opposition leader raila
odinga four of the seven members of the
electoral commission rejected the result
claiming the vote was rigged violent
protests erupted and police fired tear
gas to disperse the crowd of bodinga
supporters now kenyans are waiting to
see if odinga will contest the election
results
at least 18 children are among dozens
killed when an electrical fire swept
through a coptic church in egypt on
sunday funerals are being held for the
victims the children were aged 3 to 16.
thousands of people were attending mass
at the time officials say most of the
deaths and injuries were caused by smoke
inhalation but the panic also triggered
a stampede
it's believed the fire started on the
second floor when an air conditioner
malfunctioned building repairs are now
underway
next a family who raised millions to
find a miracle for their son's
ultra-rare disease
a few years ago we first told you about
a young toronto boy with a devastating
diagnosis
michael pirovalakis suffers from a
debilitating neurodegenerative disease
so rare he's believed to be the only
child in canada afflicted with it now
for the first time ever he's undergoing
an experimental gene therapy
specifically designed for him
that after his family raised millions to
make that treatment possible
karen lieberman has more
mama's hand yeah
you're scared that you know you're doing
something the wrong thing that you might
harm
you know this beautiful little boy but
the same time you're like you know this
could change his life it still seems
like unbelievable it like i can't
believe
we made it to that point three years
after michael pirovalakis was diagnosed
with the ultra rare condition [ __ ]
paraplegia 50 known as spg50 he became
the first to receive gene therapy with
the goal of treating it i think there
was about a hundred scientists involved
in this journey michael's parents raised
more than three million dollars to
finance the research and development of
a specialized therapy to save their son
and potentially find a cure where none
currently exists first of all we took
our life savings to start the programs
because we couldn't wait you know we had
beer stands beer markets galas soccer
tournaments
people doing little kids doing lemonade
stands on the side of the street in
march after successful testing in
animals and health canada approval the
moment they'd worked tirelessly toward a
team at toronto's sick kids hospital
delivered the individualized gene
therapy in a single patient trial to
michael and the idea behind gene therapy
is you basically replace the gene so
that now this missing protein can be
made and the idea being well hopefully
that should now
either halt whatever is happening with
the disease and maybe even reverse
things beyond helping michael and others
with rare conditions doctors believe
this could be a springboard to develop
treatments for more common conditions
you can apply the same principles of
from fundamental discovery to the
development of the drug to give to the
patient
across the continuum of disease
focus he's watching your feet michael
now undergoes daily therapy while his
family waits to see if the treatment
will work so no one really knows it's
uncharted territory you know all we're
trying to do is give him just a better
life oh my gosh
and although for michael it may just be
a treatment for the newer generation it
will be a cure right
and so
it's just like an amazing feeling
to know we're helping other people too
karen lieberman global news toronto
that is it for global national for this
monday night i'm farah nasser and on
behalf of our whole team here at global
national i want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is the city of
niagara falls ontario we love seeing
your canada so please keep emailing us
those photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]